ever wondered how to give old plastic
containers a new lease on life while
cultivating your green thumb well today
we're going to unravel the mystery of
planting eggplants in these very
containers a delightful mix of recycling
and gardening that's not just
eco-friendly but also incredibly
rewarding we begin with the selection of
the right plastic container look around
your house for an old container that's
at least 10 in deep as eggplants need
ample space to grow their Roots the size
of the container can vary depending on
the eggplant variety you choose next
step is preparing the container drill a
few holes at the bottom of the container
for drainage this is crucial to prevent
water logging and root rot then fill the
container with a good quality potting
mix make sure it's rich in organic
matter as eggplants are heavy feeders
now comes the planting part dig a hole
about 1 in deep in the center of the
potting mix place the eggplant seed in
the hole and lightly cover it with the
soil water it gently making sure not to
dislodge the seed after planting place
the container in a warm and sunny
location eggplants love sunlight and
require at least 6 hours of it every day
regular watering is key but be careful
not to overwater the soil should be kept
moist not soggy in a couple of weeks
you'll see the Sprouts emerging once the
seedlings are about 3 in tall it's time
to add some organic fertilizer to boost
their growth continue to water and care
for your eggplants and SU you'll see
lovely purple flowers blooming signaling
the arrival of the eggplant fruits
harvesting time is usually 8 to 10 weeks
from planting the fruit should be firm
and shiny use a sharp knife or scissors
to cut the eggplant from the plant
leaving a small part of the stem
attached so there you have it a
step-by-step guide to planting eggplants
in Old plastic containers let's recap
the key points one select a plastic
container that's at least 10 in deep one
prepare the container by Drilling
drainage holes and filling it with
potting mix one plant the eggplant seed
1 in deep and water gently one place the
container in a sunny location and keep
the soil moist one once the seedlings
are 3 in tall add organic fertilizer one
Harvest when the fruits are firm and
shiny usually 8 to 10 weeks from
planting this method is not only a great
way to recycle old containers but it
also allows you to enjoy fresh homegrown
eggplants right at your fingertips so
why not give it a try you might just
discover a new hobby and a love for
gardening along the
way